ja und über die Sitzung des
Innenausschusses können wir jetzt
sprechen mit Gottfried corio von der
afd-fraktion er ist in politischer
Sprecher guten Abend in die Hauptstadt
guten Abend Herr kurius sie waren ja
dabei wir bewerten sie denn den Auftritt
von vorfräser im Innenausschuss
die Antworten die Frau Feser gegeben hat
bzw die nicht antworten die wir heute
erhalten haben sind leider mit der
Vorstellung einer neutralen
unvoreingenommenen ergebnisoffenen
Aufklärung des Falles schönbum nicht
verträglich wenn sie sagt für eine
Behörde ist also 100%ige Integrität und
Vertrauenswürdigkeit unabdingbar dann
hat sie die heute für ihr eigenes Haus
nicht darstellen können was resultiert
für Sie daraus
für uns resultiert daraus dass eine
Ministerin die so viele Fragen nach
ihrem Verhalten schlicht offen lässt
nicht mehr tragbar ist es wurden so
viele Fragen kritische entscheidende
Fragen heute nach den Abläufen schlicht
nicht beantwortet dass das mit einem
Verbleib der Ministerin auf ihrem Posten
nicht fallen zu vereinbaren ist ja klare
Position dazu zu dem Besuch von Frau
Feser im Innenausschuss danach war sie
ja noch im Plenum des Deutschen
Bundestages zu Befragung der
Bundesregierung großes Thema die
aktuelle Lage in Sachen Migration jetzt
wirft ja die AFD Frau Feser unisono
total Versagen bei der Bekämpfung der
illegalen Migration vor was werfen sie
denn Frau Feser ganz konkret in dieser
aktuellen Situation vor
wir werden darüber morgen in der
Aktuellen Stunde ausführlich berichten
dass sie die großen Herausforderungen
die
Massenmigration die illegale Zuwanderung
zu stoppen zu verringern schlicht nicht
angeht schon gar nicht meistert darüber
werden wir reden dass sie die Grenzen
nicht sicher was wir stattdessen sehen
ist das der Straßenkampf der Ausländer
in die deutschen Innenstädte getragen
wird dass Gewalt gegen junge Frauen und
Mädchen in die deutschen Freibäder
getragen wird und innere weitere Anreize
nach außen gegeben werden Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht ganz früher
Staatsbürgerschaft jetzt wenn in
Lampedusa eine Armada an landet und
Frankreich sagt wir nehmen keinen dann
sagt Weser wir sind solidarisch überall
werden so anreizsignale gegeben die das
Problem nur vergrößern während es
eigentlich schon groß genug ist der
Problem Ausriss ist ja bekannt wie
würden Sie denn jetzt ganz konkret als
AFD diese konkrete Situation angehen wo
vermutlich 350.000 Menschen neu in
Deutschland in diesem Jahr aufgenommen
werden müssen
ob die aufgenommen werden müssen ist
genau die Frage wir müssen die Anreize
Herunterfahren Sachstand Geldleistung
eine alte afd-förderung die jetzt gerne
von anderen Parteien kopiert wird wir
müssen die 300.000 Ausreisepflicht in
auch mal wirklich herausschaffen aus
Deutschland wir müssen klar machen dass
wir bereits durch sich sichere
Drittstaaten gezogen ist an den Rand der
EU nicht mehr auf der Flucht und
schutzbedürftig sein kann selbst wenn er
es in seinem Flucht Ausgangsland gewesen
sein mag mit anderen Worten wir müssen
da die Begrifflichkeiten wieder vom Kopf
auf die Füße stellen es kann nicht sein
wie heute lanciert wurde bei der
Fragestunde das ist eine Flucht zu
besseren Lebensumständen gibt Frau Feser
sprach davon bei den Interviews in
Lampedusa hört man das ja wir sind
gekommen um in Europa in Deutschland
Geld zu machen ein besseres Leben zu
haben magst du aktiv verständlich sein
kann aber nicht dazu führen dass wir
eine Einwanderung in unserer
Sozialsysteme zulassen sag Gottfried
Choreo von der afd-fraktion ich sage
danke für Ihre Zeit und danke für diese
Aussagen
vielen Dank